LIEUTENANT GENERAL MICHAEL FLYNN
FOUR YEARS OF THAT THEY PUT HIM
THROUGH.
I WANT TO START WITH THIS.
AFTER THE GRUELING YEAR, LET’S
BE HONEST, IT’S A TOUGH ELECTION
YEAR FOR EVERYBODY.
THAT’S WHERE WE WANT TO START
TONIGHT.
I WENT TO SHARE SOME OF MY KEY
CONCLUSIONS.
IF I’M TELLING YOU HOW I FEEL, I
DON’T CARE, I COULD CARE LESS WH
THE FAKE, PHONY, SELECTIVE
OUTRAGE FROM THE MEDIA MOB HE
IS.
IF I’M NOT INTERESTED NOR DO I
THINK ANY OF US SHOULD BE
INTERESTED AND WANT THEY TELL US
THEY FIND OFFENSIVE.
THE SANCTIMONIOUS HIGH-MINDED
CONCERN ALL OF THE SITE ABOUT
AMERICA DEMOCRACY.
WE, FRANKLY, DON’T NEED LECTURES
ABOUT TRUTH, ABOUT INTEGRITY,
FROM WHAT IS A DEPRAVED GROUP OF
DEMOCRATIC DONORS, THE MEDIA
MOB, AND DEMOCRATS THAT NEVER
ACCEPTED THE RESULTS OF 2016.
EVER.
I DON’T CARE WHAT THEY THINK.
THEY LIE TO YOU AND US FOR FOUR
YEARS ON THE MOST SPECTACULAR
LEVEL.
THEY DRAGGED TO THIS COUNTRY
THROUGH WITH THE RUSSIAN LIES,
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, AND A HOAX
THEY PUSHED FOR YEARS.
IT WAS ALL A LIE.
THE L.A. FANS THE LIE.
THEY ALL ADVANCE THE CONSPIRACY
THEORY.
IT WAS NEVER A TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION, NO COLLUSION.
THEY PANELED THAT PHONY CLINTON
PAIDBOUGHT AND PAID FOR PHONY
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION DOSSIER
THE ONE THAT CLAIMED
DONALD TRUMP HAD, IN HIS BED.
THAT’S WHAT THEY SOLD AS TRUTH
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE FOR THREE
YEARS.
PEDDLING THE LIES.
THEY HAD NO PROBLEM WITH LEAVE
PHONY DOSSIER.
THEY NEVER DETRACT AT THE FUNNY
STORIES.
THEY DIDN’T CARE THAT THE PHONY
DOSSIER WAS USED TO SECURE FISA
WARRANTS TO SPY ON THE
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE AND THEN
A PRESIDENT FOR FOUR YEARS.
SO, ALL OF YOU IN THE MEDIA MOB,
OH, THIS IS A THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY ASKING ABOUT ELECTION
IRREGULARITIES, SAVE US YOUR
PHONY B.S. LECTURES.
THEY ARE MEANINGLESS.
IF YOU THIS COUNTRY THROUGH HECK
YOU DID IT WITH THE IMPEACHMENT
WHICH HUNT AND THEN YOU IGNORED
AND PROTECTED THE REAL
QUID PRO QUO JOE.
ZERO EXPERIENCE HUNTER.
THE FAMILY OF BIDEN AND THEIR
MASSIVE PAYOUTS.
OH, FROM THE BEAR READS MY
GROUP, THE UKRAINIAN OLIGARCH,
RUSSIAN OLIGARCHS, FIRST LADY OF
MOSCOW, THE $1.5 BILLION DEAL
WITH THE BANK OF CHINA.
OF COURSE, SHOPPING SPREES FROM
CHINESE NATIONALS.
YOU SHIELDED THE WEAK, FRAIL,
COGNITIVELY STRUGGLING JOE, THE
ENTIRE ELECTION.
THE 78-YEAR-OLD GUY, DEMOCRAT
WAS ALLOWED TO HIDE IN HIS
BASEMENT BUNKER.
THE MEDIA THAT LECTURES US NOW,
THEY ALLOW THAT.
THEY WERE BIDEN’S ATTACK DOGS,
THEY DID THE BLUDGEONING OF
TRUMP WERE BY THEN.
FOR THE MEDIA, THERE IS NO
HONESTY, NO FAIRNESS, NO
FIDELITY, TRUTH, WE DON’T NEED A
LECTURE.
A FOUR YEAR LONG AND THEY NEVER
ACCEPTED THIS PRESIDENT, TRY TO
DELEGITIMIZE THEM EVERY SECOND,
EVERY HOUR OF EVERY DAY.
>> WERE LOOKING AT THE
POSSIBILITY OF THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES AND THOSE
AROUND HIM DURING THE ELECTION
CAMPAIGN COLLUDED WITH A HOSTILE
FOREIGN POWER UNDER LYING THE
BASIS OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> WERE GOING TO FIND OUT THE
NEW PRESIDENT OF OUR COUNTRY IS
GOING TO DO WHAT RUSSIA WANTS.
>> THIS IS EVIDENCE OF
WILLINGNESS TO COMMIT COLLUSION.
>> THIS CLOWN ABOUT COLLUSION
WITH RUSSIA WILL HANG OVER HIM
WHEREVER HE STANDS.
>> SOME WILL SAY WITH CONFIDENCE
THAT THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION BETWEEN
THE CAMPAIGN IN RUSSIA.
>> WHAT IT MEANS THE FEDERAL
JUDGE FOUND THAT PEOPLE IN
TRUMP’S ORGANIZATION WERE
COLLUDED IN DEMAND WITH A RUSH
APPEARED >> IT LOOKS LIKE
COLLUSION, LISTENING TO PUTIN
MORE THAN HE IS AMERICAN
INTELLIGENCE.
FRANKLY, I’VE NEVER SEEN THAT
BEFORE.
>> Sean: THOSE SAME PACKS ARE
MENDING WE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
74 MILLION STRONG ARE FALLING IN
LINE AND ACCEPTING THEIR NEW
STANDARDS.
INVESTIGATING WHAT ARE VALID
AFFIDAVITS AND CLAIMS BY FELLOW
AMERICAN CITIZENS UNDER THE
THREAT OF PERJURY.
A FRAUD.
THIS IS A BAD JOKE.
>> D’S IN 12 HOUR PERIOD WHERE
THE PRESIDENT ASSAULTED
DEDICATED CIVIL SERVANTS WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY TRYING TO
UNDERMINE THE OUTCOME OF AN
ELECTION.
>> THESE TACTICS BOTH BY THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS CAMPAIGN, BY
REPUBLICANS TO SUPPORT HIM, THAT
AFTER THE ELECTION, THE ELECTION
OFFICIALS ARE NOW SUBJECT TO
LOBBYING, PRESSURE, OR THREATS.
THE ONLY WAY TO STOP THAT’S
BECOMING THE NEW NORMAL AT LEAST
IN REPUBLICAN POLITICS, IS FOR S
FOR IT.
>> I NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD SEE A
DAY WHERE YOU SAW PRETTY MUCH AN
ENTIRE PARTY IN THIS COUNTRY
REFUSED TO ACCEPT ELECTION
RESULTS.
>> Sean: AMAZING HOW THEY
CHANGED, FOR YEARS THEY LINED
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION THAT
HILLARY PLAYED FOR.
THERE ARE THAT OUT OF TOUCH.
THAT’S THE MOB, THAT’S WHAT I
CALLED THE MEDIA MOB.
THEY’RE NOT LOOKING FOR, THERE
IS NOTHING MORE THAN A GLORIFIED
OVERPAID WEIGHT.
THEY WILL SPREAD LIES,
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, TEMPER
TANTRUMS, GIVE US THE LECTURES,
AND WE CAN TAKE A FEW WEEKS TO
INVESTIGATE ELECTION
IRREGULARITIES.
NEW POLITICAL SURVEY, 80% OF
TRUMP VOTERS BELIEVE THE
ELECTION WAS TAINTED WITH FRAUD.
IF YOU HAVE EVERY RIGHT NOT TO
HAVE FAITH IN CONGRESS AND WHY
DID ALL THE OTHER STATES GET IT
RIGHT?
WE HAVE A RIGHT TO BE CONCERNED